[Musique]
je pense que monsieur verdès poursuit
sur doute une juste cause me eelv est
l'avocat de gens qui se sentent attaqués
c'est ça pour autant je pense que les
côtes s'est proposé de renforcer les
pensées extrême on dirait que plus
quelque part une polémique pour un verre
d'eau ou la république prend l'eau et on
en ajoute où on en enlève et j'ai le
sentiment que les vieilles on a
peut-être été maladroit
peut-être mais je pense que vous avez
été très maladroit en donnant un écho
dans une émission aussi forte et les
gens qui les entourent autour de moi de
toutes confessions d'ailleurs ne
comprennent pas cette posture alors je
maintiens totalement mes propos je vous
avoue que la journée est difficile parce
qu'il ya quand même un non pas un
déferlement mais ma prise de position je
sais est minoritaire et là il ya eu
énormément de messages négatifs et
beaucoup d'occasions quel type de
message que ça alors il ya eu beaucoup
de messages et c'est bien que monsieur
messia soit là parce qu'il ya eu
énormément de messages lancés par les
séides extrême droite de monsieur messia
après un tweet qu'il a bien su hier soir
au mot près ce qu'il est mais ça on va
voir on peut voir le besoin de joueurs
ont été plus de pouvoir alors messieurs
gilles verdez perd les pédales pour lui
et mes enfants seraient coupables d'
islamophobie et d'attaqués contre le
ramadan pour un tweet sur la
consommation d'eau il y à un traitement
pour l'islamo gauchisme démentiel point
d'interrogation à la longue ça c'est
violent et je dois vous dire que c'est
l'avis de monsieur mais c'est assez qui
lancé ses idées sa défaire leurs déchets
et je reconnais aussi monsieur je
reconnais aussi et je le dis avec totale
honnêteté cyril que beaucoup de
musulmans
beaucoup de musulmans mondy m'ont dit je
ne suis pas sûr que ta position malgré
la bonne volonté que tu avais été très à
droite parce que ça peut nous créer des
problèmes alors que nous on veut faire
le ramadan tranquillement three leverdez
est un vautour de l'islamo gauchisme
d'accord dès qu'il voit un truc qu'il
peut arrêter avec la racaille aux
sphères où l'islam au ce faire ils font
dessus pour s'envoler avec enfin
franchement accusé le groupe danone qui
est l'un des groupes qui a le plus fait
en matière de diversité en matière
d'inclusion en matière d'environnement
d'islamophobie
c'est vraiment se [ __ ] de la gueule
des créateurs quévillon fait partie du
groupe danone on les soigne gilles
verdez dans votre entourage vous avez
des personnes qui font le ramadan et qui
vous ont dit oui ça m'a choqué non vous
êtes le seul du monde
entourage avait beaucoup de personnes
dans votre de personnes qui font le
ramadan dans mon entourage est très
majoritairement je suis honnête avec
vous il ya huit personnes sur dix qui
m'ont dit que
ça ne valait pas le coup d'en faire une
polémique parce que ça devait être il
fallait que ce soit une erreur mais ces
personnes là me disais aussi j'espère
que c'est une erreur j'espère que tu
encore été toutes les pubs sur la
journée sera majeur que non toutes les
pubs toutes les pubs pour la bouffe et
les boissons pendant le ramadan doivent
être interdites alors est ce que vous
dites est arrêté mais là il ya eu une
organisation lancée par jean bessière a
été mise en pratique et la deux il ya
deux personnes qui le suivent les pas de
gp national si l'on suivait de followers
qui a lancé réjean contre vous c'est
votre propre il y aussi les c'est une y
en a un peu plus et ces gens là sont
actifs et mais il ya eu un déferlement
de l'extrême droite avec des menaces
précises sur moi sur mon entourage qui
donnez nous des exemples c'est tu
deviendras pas quand tu vas te faire
agresser un jour